Biden. And today I'll be talking about marginal zone lymphoma and some of the new approaches,
particularly in the first line. So as you heard from the prior speakers, marginal zone lymphoma
is one of the, it's the second most common end of lymphoma. And it's really a hodgepodge of
different slow growing lymphomas. So we all face this in the clinic sometimes trying to,
you know, figure out if a lot of times you get a pathology report that says CD5 negative,
CD10 negative low-grade lymphoma with a differential, you know, marginal zone lymphoma.
It could be a plasmacetic, it could be a hairy cell. And this is when sometimes NGS could help
with MYD88 or some of the other, you know, the markers that we look at. Most common is
external marginal zone lymphoma. But again, you have many of them. So if you have cutaneous,
you have the, the,
the gastric, you have some of them that involve the salivary glands, the lungs, the livers. So
again, it's, it's a hodgepodge of different things. There's the nodal marginal zone lymphoma that looks
like a follicular lymphoma a lot of times. And then you have this clinic marginal zone lymphoma,
which mimics, you know, the CLL or it has leukemia. A lot of times they'll come in with
peripheral blood involvement, marrow involvement, clinic involvement as well. What is unique about
marginal zone lymphoma is it's, it's actually something that we have.
Some better understanding about the pathophysiology, unlike a lot of the other
homas. And one of the key things here is chronic antigen stimulation, whether it be with,
you know, infectious agents, for example, H. pylori in gastric or, or chlamydia on the,
in the ocular adnexal ones, hepatitis C and splenic marginal zone lymphoma or autoimmune
diseases like Sjogren's disease or, or lupus with some of these marginal zone lymphomas as well.
The key to all these things is they lead to intracellular continuous BCR signaling which is
really key to marginal zone lymphoma pathogenesis. And all these at the end lead to BTK
phosphorylation and downstream activation of different pathways, including NF-kappa B, among
others as well. There's, of course, some unique mutations here. MYD88 is positive in about 10 to
15 percent of these patients, among other drivers as well.
And what I'm trying to get to is, you know, a lot of these, it makes sense clinically that
BTK inhibition would be a very good target in marginal zone lymphoma for that reason.
For, for, for treatment in the first line, so observation is obviously, you know,
what's recommended for a lot of patients with low-bulk disease, radiation sometimes for,
for early stage disease, rituximab monotherapy or chemoimmune therapy is, is still recommended.
But we do have a key unmet need in marginal zone lymphoma, which is, we really need a
chemotherapy-free upfront treatment that's not just rituximab and it's for patients who have
bulky disease. Because at this time, still a lot, the majority of these patients are receiving
chemoimmune therapy. There's, of course, of course, rituximab and lenalidomide, but again,
it's, it's something that's not based on prospective trials. As a matter of fact,
marginal zone lymphoma, I always, you know,
call it the stepson of, of endo-lymphomas because most of the, the trials that we have, they've,
the marginal zone lymphoma patients are typically included as, as you know, in, in bigger follicular
lymphoma treatments. So there's actually one, it's, it's, it's, it's very interesting. We only
have one frontline randomized phase three trial in marginal zone lymphoma, and you're not going to be
very excited about it. I mean, it's chlorambucil versus rituximab, chlorambucil versus rifactimab.
So again,
there is a, you know, there's a big unmet need in generating prospective data
in marginal zone lymphoma, particularly chemotherapy-free options. If you ask in the
community, you're going to see that, you know, a lot of the patients who have bulky disease,
what are they getting? They're getting rituximab and namaste. What is that based on? It's mostly
retrospective studies and, and, and Dr. Losos had, you know, summarized a lot of these in
his prior presentation. As a matter of fact, we worked with,
you know, with Juan Aldruchio on, on, on one of these projects that we have here,
where we basically just looked at, you know, retrospectively at 237 patients who
received rituximab and namaste, again, because of the lack of prospective data.
In the relapsed setting, again, there is the availability still of chemoimmunotherapy,
but this is where BTK inhibitors are currently approved. The only one that's currently FDA
approved is Xanabrutinib. In later lines of therapy, there's, of course, CAR-T-cell therapy,
but again, that's based on studies, the Zuma 5 and the Transcend study that,
that were mainly targeting follicular lymphoma. As I mentioned, in terms of BTK inhibitors,
Xanabrutinib is currently the only FDA approved one. The initial approval for abrutinib,
unfortunately, you know, there was a voluntary withdrawal afterwards because of the,
the prospective study later on, the CELINE trial, didn't meet its primary EFS. Acalabrutinib is,
at times, also used on an off-label basis. So, the Xanabrutinib approval came based on
the Magnolia study, which was a single-arm study, including 68 patients with, patients with relapsed
refractory marginal lymphoma who have received at least one prior line of therapy. The overall
response here was 68%, and you could see the different, you know, it was pretty, you know,
similar across the board between different subtypes. Of course, the CR rates and whatnot,
I, you know, I don't want you to get too carried away with them because, again, the, you know,
once you start looking at these subgroups, the numbers, you know, are, become much smaller.
So, there's currently an ongoing prospective phase three trial, the Mahogany study,
and this will have two cohorts looking at follicular lymphoma and marginal
lymphoma cohorts in the relapsed setting. For the follicular lymphoma,
that's going to be Xanabrutinib abinituzumab versus R-squared, and in the marginal zone lymphoma
cohort, that's going to be Xanabrutinib rituximab versus R-squared. So, again, you know, we're going
to wait, but again, you know, it's great that we're now seeing, you know, interest in marginal
zone lymphoma with studies focusing, you know, primarily on marginal zone lymphoma rather than,
you know, include it as a subset of follicular lymphoma patients. We have an IIT at Moffitt
looking at Xanabrutinib rituximab in the first line setting. It has two arms. One is with,
it's for marginal zone lymphoma, dedicated marginal zone lymphoma. The other one is for
follicular lymphoma. The thing about this trial is it's, you know, we wanted to generate data,
it's a time limited. So, as, you know, as of right now in the relapsed or factory setting,
typically you're doing the, you know, the BTK inhibitor till disease progression,
and the question is, do you really need, you know, to keep those patients indefinitely, you know,
to keep those patients indefinitely. So, you know, as of right now in the relapsed or factory setting,
typically you're doing the, you know, the BTK inhibitor till disease progression, and the question is,
do you really need, you know, to keep those patients indefinitely if you add rituximab to it.
So, we have MRD data, you know, MRD samples at different time points collected, and we're
partnering with Natera to look at that MRD dynamics. And, you know, if we're starting to see
that, hey, you know, these patients are achieving MRD early on, maybe a fixed duration therapy might
make sense. So, that's gonna, you know, to be determined. And I just wanted to include like,
you know, just like one patient here,
as a case study, this is a nodal marginal zone lymphoma, and you could see, you know,
clearly see here the lymph nodes, and this was the PET scan at three months, and you could see
that pretty much all of them had disappeared. At this time, the overall response that we're seeing,
again, it's a trial in progress, but so far, the overall response has been about 100%,
and, you know, all the patients have responded. But again, I think the key question is,
how much relapses are we gonna see when we stop the Xanabrutinib,
and, you know, that's to be determined. And thank you. I went a bit over time. Thank you.